hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in part one of
the spoke zarathustra
one theme that Friedrich Nietzsche
brings up quite a bit and it's straddle
several of the sections is that of
solitude what is it to have genuine
solitude what is it to be a solitary
person and in German the word for
solitude is enzyme kite being literally
enzym on one's own right and it can be
translated as solitude which is a
generally a positive connotation to it
it can also be translated as loneliness
and this is a great theme running
throughout literature prior to Nietzsche
and also taken up by other people after
him there is a conception in which
solitude is something necessary for us
as human beings in order to develop and
grow so we can't be entirely what we
ought to be or what we're capable of
being if we're taking all of our cues
from other people or from society and
not from our own not just experience but
our own reflections on in our own
engagement in that
experience which may not be shared and
in some respects cannot be shared with
other people so the solitary person is
in certain respects a strange creature
and and there felt to be strange as we
see in the discussion of the flies of
the marketplace by all the other people
who seem to be much better
socialized there's a possibility of
going too far with socialization we
could say so that a person lacks what we
call an interior life but this is an
interior life that is also oriented
towards the exterior that sees more than
the other people do so the the two
sections that really come out as
particularly important are as Ann
mentioned the of the Flies in the
marketplace and then the section that
just preceded it which is about the
development and the extent of the state
called of the new idle there nietzsche
mentions that the solitary person is the
one who can escape this dynamic created
by the state so nietzsche thinks that
this is something that we we absolutely
need but it's made incredibly difficult
by modern society there are so many
temptations so many assaults upon our
solitude and I'll just give you one as
an example of our own time that
Nietzsche himself you know could have
imagined but didn't have to experience
and that is whenever you go into public
spaces these days if they can afford it
there is a television blaring you know
usually set right in the middle of
things so that it draws your eyes and
it's tuned into either the news or some
stupid talk show or some you know kind
of low low-key drama something to just
keep people occupied and have you know
Talking Heads chattering at each other
the entire time
and that makes it difficult I often go
in carrying a book and find myself
having trouble concentrating you know at
for example a doctor's office on what's
in the book because of this this you
know constant chattering of the
television personalities and I look
around and I see people's eyes glued to
the set that would be a prime example
and sort of a symbol of the lack of
solitude why the hell would you put
televisions everywhere because it's
going to make people's lives better it's
going to give them something to do
wouldn't it be better for them to
actually sit with their own thoughts for
a while
that's what Nietzsche would say but most
people are actually not capable or if
they're if they are capable they choose
not to be with their own thoughts and
ideas and feelings and reflections and
memories and they don't cultivate this
to this solitude so Nietzsche talks
about the state and society within it
I'm just gonna highlight a few passages
from this he talks about the state as
being the place for superfluous people
it manages even to suck in the better
the higher people and you know give them
a sort of devil's bargain of we're gonna
make you famous we're gonna give you
power we're going to you know make the
ordinary people look up to you and you
just have to you know follow the rules
of the state you'll be domesticated so
to speak and everything will go great
now Nietzsche says the the state is a
place where everyone good and bad is a
poison drinker the state where everyone
good and bad loses themselves the state
where universal slow suicide is called
life and then he talks about you know
culture building in German he talks
about the newspapers so the media he
talks about wealth and people's
obsession with it and then he says see
them clamber these nimble apes they
clamber over one another and so scuffle
into the mud and
to the abyss and he says this seems like
madmen and clambering Apes and too
vehement their idle the cold monster is
the state and he says do you want to
suffocate in the fumes of this no better
to break the window and leap into the
open air better to seek out a space of
solitude for oneself
he says the earth still remains free for
great Souls many places the odour of
tranquil seas blowing about them are
still empty and here he talks about
solitaries and solitary couples which
could be you know some sort of you know
romantic pairing or it could be friends
or it could be perhaps even enemies who
can can recognize the right kind of
enemy and in the other person or rivals
we might say but they leave the state
and the society behind them and the
questions that we could ask ourselves is
does this have to mean going out into
some foreign place that's been unsettled
not a lot of those left these days in
the much longer and in-depth discussion
about the marketplace nietzsche brings
up the need for solitude as well and he
says flee into your solitude I see you
deafened by the uproar of the great men
and pricked by the stings of the small
one so again we see the same dynamic
this this distinction of the great
people and they are doing one thing and
then there's the many the small people
and they're also doing something as well
so he tells us that in this world the
world of the marketplace even the best
things are worthless apart from him who
first presents them people call these
presenters great men what would be some
examples of this well think about all
the people who we idolize because they
came up with a new business model and we
say oh my god they're coming to town
we'd better go to their their
presentation Oh they've got a new blog
post out or no video I'd better check up
on this person or this person they are
what Nietzsche would call the the great
men in this case or great people they're
looked up to because they brought in
some
some new gimmick some new shtick very
often it's not even original you know
you see this in in business and you see
this in education and you see this in
policing and you see this in all these
other fields people can recycle all the
ideas and give them a new twist and
change the colours on the PowerPoint
presentation and suddenly they've come
up with a wonderful new plan right and
and you know a lot of it has to do with
marketing and and with finding you know
ways to appeal to people you know
nowadays we talk about life hacks we
will talk about the same stupid thing in
different words ten years down the line
right people are tired of life hacks
already we're already coming up with new
things for that all of that is what
Nietzsche would call the great men and
they're not really great they're just
recognized as being great within the
marketplace and that defens us they're
on TV all the time these celebrities
these people who are viewed as actually
having something to say and it affects
even intellectual life you can go to
conferences and here the hushed tones as
this person oh my god I can't believe
that they're here and they're gonna do a
talk they put on their pants the same
way that all the rest of us do one leg
at a time sometimes tripping and
slipping into that falling on the floor
right so that's that's what he's calling
the great men then of course there's the
little people and he calls them the
Flies and he's using that as sort of a
metaphor what kind of flies that kind of
flies that swarm around on crap no the
biting stinging flies if you've ever
been out say camping near a lake and you
had deer flies biting you they're
actually putting there they're not
actually biting into you they're
actually putting their liquid their
digestive juices onto you onto your skin
kind of hurts right and we could think
about other insects that suck our blood
and and make us weaker ticks you know
vermin of that sort so he says the
market place is full of solemn buffoons
and the people boast of their great men
these are the heroes of the hour they're
made so by the little people and he says
that I see you stung by poisonous flies
flee into your solitude then you've
lived too near the small and the
pitiable men flee from their hidden
vengeance now why does Nietzsche talk
about hidden vengeance here because even
though the weak will and the small will
make some people into big people they
really hate them they wish they could be
like them they don't have the forces the
capacity to do that so they're
constantly stinging and detracting and
if you're not willing to play their game
like the big men are the big people who
you know will sign the autographs and
bask in the applause and you know say
stupid things so that they can have
approval you know here's here's another
thing Nietzsche says a truth that
penetrates only sensitive ears this
person of the marketplace calls a lie in
a thing of nothing right so if you're
actually telling the real truth about
things the ordinary people are not going
to reward you for that they are gonna
dislike you they want things made simple
a theme we'll come back to in a moment
but let's stick with the flies theme he
says innumerable are these small and
pitiable men and raindrops and weeds
have already brought about the
destruction of many a proud building if
you're not careful they will bring you
down with a little bit here and a little
bit there and a little bit here and a
zinger here and one more thing that you
have to deal with he says you're not a
stone these drops have already made you
Hollow you're not made of iron they will
eventually tear you down if you don't go
into solitude he says they're
innumerable and it's not your fate to be
a flyswatter it's not your job to try to
ward off all of these go somewhere else
where you can in fact enjoy solitude
going out a little bit more II says they
want blood from you and all innocence
they're bloodless Souls thirst for it
you
suffer to profoundly even from small
wounds and before you have recovered the
same poison worm is crawling over your
hand you're too proud to kill these
sweet tooth preachers but take care it
does not become your faith to bear all
their poisonous injustice you should
push back but realize that you can never
push back against all of them and the
more that you're exposed by being in the
marketplace by being for example in
social media opening yourself up to the
entire world the greater the danger is
that all those little pricks and stings
and and you know criticisms will in fact
bring you down SAP your vital powers he
says here we go they think about you a
great deal with their narrow Souls
you're always suspicious to them
everything that's thought about a great
deal is finally thought suspicious they
will punish you for your virtues
fundamentally they forgive you only what
your mistakes because your mistakes make
you more like them and then they can
feel okay because there's only he or
she's not that great at all another
aspect of this that I said would come
back to theirs
Nietzsche frames it in terms of these
demands of saying yes or no being for
and against declaring yourself on all
sorts of trivial and misunderstood
matters are you a Democrat or a
Republican which candidate are you going
to support what if you say well both of
them are crap and both of these parties
are awful perhaps one is more awful than
the other but they're both a big mess of
problems oh well then you know you're
you're going to be attacked right
because you don't fit in nicely or now
we have it actually the centrist where
they can be their own thing but you have
to be a centrist in the right way and we
can go on and on and on it could be
music it could be religion it could be
art forms it could be whether the tech
revolution is good or bad it could be
whatever the object of the day is in
terms of the thing that everybody is
talking about
you should have a position you should
have some way of staking out which side
you belong to now the the solitary
person the thinking person is not really
going to want to do that they're gonna
want to pause and say well I think I
need to get more information no you need
to take a stand right now for or against
I'll give you another example of this
from social media how often when you
criticize somebody or or something on
one side of an issue does everybody
assume that because of that you're
entirely committed to the other side of
the issue if you criticize capitalism
you must be a communist if you criticize
communism you must be one of those
capitalists running dogs and on and on
and on that's because they are stuck in
that binary over simplistic thinking
that works well for what what Nietzsche
is calling the marketplace he says
you're a bad conscience to your neighbor
they're unworthy of you that's why they
hate you and would dearly like to suck
your blood you show them up you show
them that there's greater possibility
for human beings than what they're
showing now where is solitude possible
Nietzsche begins this section by talking
about nature he says forests and rock no
well how to be silent with you be like
the tree again the wide branching tree
that you love calmly and attentively it
leans out to the sea and indeed nature
is one place where I think many people
can attain solitude but it couldn't it
doesn't have to just be that we could
attain solitude in the heart of the city
looking at the concrete structures that
maybe are not covered entirely with
advertisement and screens
you know blaring words and lessons and
enticements out to us but just looking
at the architecture itself looking at
the sidewalk nature is also present
within
the urbanized world fine parks look at
the grass growing through the cracks of
the sidewalk sometimes even you know on
on ramps I've seen that in New Jersey
getting onto the highway where grass
either had been allowed to run riot or
it was so strong that you could actually
see it on the on-ramp driving up onto
the freeway there is all sorts of
possibilities in places where we can
have solitude it's more about shifting
our mentality and recognizing for
Nietzsche the dangers that are out there
he also talks about the possibility of
shared solitude and this comes up again
in that of the new Idol where he says
that you know many places are still
empty for solitaries individual
solitaries and for solitary couples and
the question that you would have to ask
is well is this them sharing the exact
same solitude or are they both in fact
solitudes and then they share a greater
solitude with each other and to
understand that I think it's good to
take a look at the section of the friend
and I'll just mention this very quickly
because it deserves its own treatment
separately
Nietzsche talks about the the Hermit in
this case the Hermit is somebody who
goes off into the wilderness and chooses
a life of solitude and for that he says
for the Hermit the friend is always the
third person why because the Hermit is
having a conversation with him or
herself and then the friend comes in as
another person he says that the third
person is the cork that prevents the
conversation from sinking into the depth
for the Hermit there are actually too
many depths and this is why they they
need a friend and their Heights so
perhaps solitude is something that if we
don't have somebody else to share it
with we have to endure on our own and
it's better than being in the
marketplace or the state in society
that goes with it but if we have the
possibility of finding another who
recognizes the value of Solitude we can
share solitude together for Nietzsche
this is going to be something absolutely
necessary something absolutely needed
for a human being to fully develop
you